more people arrive at this putin in the
northern part of khartoum it's now in
its fifth day protesters here are
demanding the military abandon politics
after it took power last october the
army announced on monday it was
withdrawing from talks to form a
transitional government to pave way for
political parties to reach an agreement
but organizers of the setting known as
resistance committees are continuing
with their protests
we think the statement from the army is
just a political process and a play with
words when we say we want them to return
to the barracks it's not just about them
leading politics it's about the reform
of the security sector
ensuring that their role is clearly
defined and making sure that they don't
have access to wealth that should be
going into the government coffers
bahrain is one of many such protests in
khartoum they started after mass
protests last month left nine people
dead and hundreds injured when security
forces used tear gas and live ammunition
to disperse demonstrations protesters
here say the army's talk of withdrawal
fails to meet their demands
we want to end the military rule because
a lot of people are suffering since they
took charge three years ago nothing has
changed and even with the army saying
it's withdrawing from talks there's been
no justice yet for the protesters killed
so we're not going anywhere
the talks were being facilitated by the
un along with the african union and the
regional body igad following the army's
withdrawal the tripartite mechanism
announced it was cancelling negotiations
and will consult political parties and
stakeholders on a new format to end
sudan's political crisis
there have been varied reactions from
political parties while some have
announced they are ready to sit down and
find ways to form a transitional
government others have denounced the
army's withdrawal rejected the
possibility of further talks and called
for more protests
as the tripartite mechanism tries to
bring the parties together resistance
committees say they will work to ensure
any deal reach is accepted by protesters
resistance committees are monitoring
bodies before being executive bodies we
will support political parties to make
sure they appoint a government of
technocrats that can work for the people
and not affiliated to any political
party our demands are very clear we want
a government with competent people that
can deliver
but it's not clear when or if that
government will be formed sudan's road
to political stability still appears a
long one hiba morgan al-jazeera khartoum